Oh Rebecca is post-modernism in any way
relevant to the post truth debate is the
attack on a sort of linear idea of
progress part of what then breaks up the
discourse yeah so well yes I think to
some extent but it's a it was a the post
modernist I don't think we're so widely
read they're very difficult to read
aren't they it's just plotted with
jargon
and and yeah I often wonder whether they
know what they're talking about would
you like to save any names being videos
no yes and then of course all my friends
who identify as postmodern are
exceptions to what I've just said you
ought to have told me it was being
videoed before I don't know that that
really has had the place that I think
the the movement that I think really had
an effect were there so-called science
Wars of several decades back started
very much by by Thomas Kuhn the
structure of scientific revolution it
was widely influential book I'm told
it's still the most widely assigned book
at least in American colleges and this
was a an interpretation of science which
I actually might my specialty is
philosophy of science that's what I had
begun in it's something I completely
disagree with I am a scientific realist
and as most scientists are I think
they're in laws of nature and we don't
know them absolutely that's what the
whole scientific method geology is about
we keep falsifying but we're getting
closer and closer and when certain
things that we do know for example that
carbon emissions cause
global warming parallel its perilous to
doubt that and but this view of Kuhn
that's all a paradigm shift it's akin to
a religious conversion it's a power-play
this the exports of the people who are
the most powerful who get declared to be
the experts they're the one who we
manufacture the truth they change the
rules of the game this this
interpretation and paradigm shift if
became one of the most overused memes
it's a meme yeah I says I've seen it on
subway advertisements you know change
your shoes change change your paradigm I
think all sorts of so I think that this
had a very my mind
dila Terius effect and prepared the way
for a thinking you know there is no
truth and also for for mistrusting
experts because for some truths not all
truths but for some truths we need
experts we need we need people's devoted
their entire life to being trained for
this sort of thing for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you